upper Moon 5 gyoko is one of the sickest
most depraved villains that you'll ever
meet and by the end of this video you
will know everything there is to know
about his powers and his secret
backstory including information that
wasn't even in the manga and can only be
found in extra materials like fan books
that still haven't even gotten
unofficial English translation
thankfully I got you covered with all
the disturbing details so let's get into
it if you guys enjoy our Demon Slayer
content and you want to see more in the
future leave a quick like and comment
right now it only takes you a second but
it helps us with that YouTube algorithm
and quick fact over half of you guys who
watch our videos regularly haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a big
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
right now subscribing on YouTube is
completely free but it is a very real
way of directly supporting the channel
okay so as I said very little is
revealed about yoko's backstory in the
actual manga but we do get some
information in the second Demon Slayer
fan book as a human his name was manaki
and he was an outcast who lived on the
outskirts of a coastal fishing Village
he was considered to be a weirdo by
everyone inside the village and he
apparently collected fish carcasses in
his spare time and did other weird and
creepy things as well monarchy lost his
parents at a young age they were both
fishermen and on one of his fishing
trips they had an accident and drowned
once the bodies of his parents were
recovered they were badly decomposed but
managi thought that the bodies of his
dead parents were beautiful and he
became fascinated by them this is a
massive red flag if I've ever seen one I
mean if you ever see a character in any
crime show or horror movie who was like
fascinated by dead bodies and thinks
they're beautiful you better believe
that character is going to turn out to
be the insane serial killer that
everyone's been looking for the entire
time anyway one day one of the The
Village children began teasing managi
for being so weird Mamaki then killed
the child and stuffed the child's body
in a big pot when the child's parents
found out they attacked monarchy stabbed
him with a two-pronged fishing fork and
left him to die but managi was stubborn
and he clung to life nearly half a day
despite being severely injured we don't
really know the specific details of this
incident but you definitely can't blame
the parents for doing what they did to
manaki sure if the kid just went to
tease him for no reason that's obviously
wrong but it's still just a kid and
there is no excuse whatsoever for doing
what this freak did around the time that
monarchy was slowly dying from his
wounds muzon just happened to come
across him and he was impressed by the
fact that monarchy was stubbornly
clinging to life muzan decided to turn
monagee into a demon and that is when he
became known as gyoko as a demon gyoko
developed a taste for human flesh and
especially for children this guy
definitely deserved to die but but
thanks to muzan's appearance it was not
to be he eventually Rose to the rank of
the fifth strongest demon after muzon
himself in terms of Personality along
with being a sadistic killer who
especially targets children gyoko also
seems to despise all living creatures
The Only Exception is muzon gyoko has a
sick infatuation with muzan and he goes
out of his way to prove himself to muzan
and to make him happy he feels terrible
if muzan ever scolds him and he wants to
show his master that he is more useful
than the other demon moons in his demon
form gyoko is a grotesque creature with
two mouths where his eyes should be and
an eye in his mouth and on his forehead
he also has small child-like arms
popping out randomly from his body which
adds yet another layer to this guy's
already record-breaking levels of
creepiness in his first demon form he
looks like a genie who lives inside a
large ornately decorated vase his design
features fish-based elements to go along
with his fascination with fish carcasses
and this is especially evident in his
final form his true demon form in which
he looks less like a genie and more like
a humanoid merman along with upper Moon
4 huntengu Yoko is the main antagonist
of the swordsmith village arc when we
first see Yoko during the big meeting of
the upper moons he emerges from a vase
and engages in small talk with akaza
Doma and the others but the only person
that gyoko is really interested in is
his master and he is extremely eager to
please Him Yoko emphasizes that he has
important information about the demon
Slayers and he stresses that this makes
him more useful to muzon than the other
upper moons Kyoko especially wants to
make his usefulness known at this
particular time because during the
meeting muzan expresses his
disappointment in the upper moons and
implies that they are all useless but
after gyoko offers up some secret
information to muzan his master
violently removes his head from his body
before gyoko even realizes what happened
muzan then proceeds to monologue about
how he hates change while holding yoko's
head in his hand muzan essentially
removed yoko's head just to make a point
and just to remind the upper moons how
strong and how fast he really is but
Yoko isn't upset by muzon's unwarranted
attack in fact he takes a sick pleasure
in the fact that muzan is touching his
head and he calls the experience Sublime
this brief scene alone tells us just how
messed up Yoko truly is the man is a
living breathing red flag in terms of
power we already know that Yoko is an
extremely powerful demon because he is
one of the upper moons we usually pay
the most attention to the upper three
because they are stronger and let's face
it they are cooler than saying Yoko and
huntingu but we can't forget that Yoko
is considered stronger than Doki and
yutaro and they were known for killing
22 hashira between them so is no joke
and he has all the regular powers that
demons possess including regeneration
and flesh manipulation but as an upper
Moon his abilities are at the highest
end of the scale the fact that he
survived being beheaded by muzan without
even showing signs of pain or suffering
tells us right away that gyoko is
extremely tough and durable yoko's demon
blood art is centered around porcelain
pots or vases and around water and sea
creatures he can create multiple parts
of different sizes and distribute them
all around him he is then able to
instantly teleport from one paw to
another which makes him incredibly
difficult to pin down in battle he can
also trap his opponents inside these
pots and then drown them in water or do
some other sick thing that he has
planned for them once he gets them
inside a pot Yoko can also create
grotesque fish monsters of various
shapes and sizes and launch them at his
opponents he can summon giant octopus
tentacles from his pots and use them to
attack or restrain his enemy ease and so
on essentially his blood demon art is
very versatile and unpredictable but the
one thing that all of his abilities have
in common is their aquatic theme fun
fact but at the start of the series
gyoko is actually one of muzan's main
sources of income along with doci the
pots and vases that gyoko creates are
extremely expensive and muzan is able to
make a lot of money by selling them
after the meeting of the upper moons
huntingu and gyoko are dispatched by
muzon on a big mission that information
that Yoko wanted to share with muzan at
the meeting was the top secret location
of the swordsmith village a critically
important Demon Slayer sanctuary and so
the two demon moons are then sent out to
attack the village theoko makes his
appearance inside the village after an
unsuspecting villager stumbles upon a
vase in the middle of a path as the
Villager reaches for the vase he is
sucked in and devoured but Yoko then
spits him back up saying that the taste
is awful the Flesh of Amir swordsmith
isn't good enough for gyoko he demands
something more appetizing and just a
quick warning for everyone but I will be
spoiling what happens to gyoko during
the swordsmith village Arc in the rest
of the video so proceed with caution you
have been warned at the same time that
gyoko is initiating his attack on the
village huntegu is also making his move
both demons know that muzan is angry and
they have to prove their usefulness to
him as soon as possible their plan is to
kill everyone inside the swordsmith
village because this would be a massive
setback to the organizational structure
of the Demon Slayer core and it could
lead to the organization's ultimate
downfall there's a reason why the
location of the village was such a
closely guarded secret the demon Slayers
need their swordsmiths to keep fighting
and without this Village and its
inhabitants the Demon Slayer core would
be in big trouble
was initially engaged in combat against
hunting but after he is blown away from
the battlefield by one of hantangu's
attacks he comes across a demonic fish
monster that must have been created by a
powerful demon the fish monster itself
doesn't pose a challenge to muichiro but
while attempting to protect the
villagers from these sea monsters
muichiro eventually comes face to face
with gyoko himself being the sick Maniac
that he is yoko's first instinct upon
meeting muichiro is to show off the
bodies of five swordsmiths that he had
arranged into some sort of grotesque art
piece he then starts rambling about the
artistic Merit of his creation but
michiro Cuts him off and engages him in
battle Yoko is able to evade muichiro's
attacks by traveling instantly between
the pots and vases that he has arranged
throughout the area he is also able to
launch poison needles at muichiro and he
then manages to use his blood demon art
to capture inside a giant pot filled
with water now unable to breathe
muichiro can't use his breathing style
and so it looks like he is about to
drown in a moment of short-sighted
egomania reminiscent of James Bond
villains Joko just leaves muichiro to
die on his own while he pursues other
targets inside the village but after
gyoko leaves muichiro is rescued thanks
to a young swordsmith named kotetsu who
helps muichiro at Great cost to himself
kotatsu's sacrifice inspires muichiro to
dedicate himself wholeheartedly to
saving the others and this allows him to
unlock the Demon Slayer Mark now
stronger than ever before muichiro
confronts gyoko once again Yoko tries to
use his blood demon art to throw a bunch
of squid and fish and other sea monsters
at muichiro but the hashira is able to
use missed breathing to protect himself
from all of those attacks Yoko is then
forced to reveal feel his true form in
which he looks like a scaly demonic
merman he now has normal arms and a long
eel-like tail meaning that he is no
longer confined to a pot the upper Moon
5 and the Mist hashira then engage in an
absolutely epic battle but the newly
powered up muichiro is full of
confidence and he proves to be too
strong for Kyoko who continuously makes
the mistake of underestimating our boy
muichiro using missed breathing seventh
form obscuring clouds muichiro emerges
from the mist and relieves gyoko of his
head using his nichirin blade muichiro's
ultimate success came from the fact that
he was able to use wildly fluctuating
speed in his movements to confuse gyoko
and in the end the hashira's superb
speed and technique was just too much
for the demon gyoko is an utter
disbelief about being defeated by a mere
human child but it was precisely that
over confidence that destroyed gyoko in
the end he could have easily finished
muichiro off while the boy was drowning
inside that part but gyoko was
overconfident and he just assumed that
muichiro would die on his own he assumed
that the battle was over before making
sure that it was indeed over and that is
what cost him his life in the end all
things considered gyoko did not turn out
to be a very important villain in the
story yes he was one of the two main
antagonists of the swordsmith village
Arc but he meets his end during the arc
less than two dozen chapters after he
was introduced but that's not to say
that he wasn't a memorable villain
because he certainly was as one of the
upper moons he was clearly strong and he
had an extremely versatile and Powerful
blood demon art his exhibitionism his
perverse taste in art and his lack of
any regard for human life also made him
memorable because it's hard not to
remember a villain who is such a sick
sick freak nevertheless gyoko also had
blatant character flaws and these flaws
led to his ultimate downfall and
although you may not realize it at first
yoko's flaws also speak to the flaws of
demon daddy moves on himself and they
foreshadow muzan's own downfall Yoko is
an extremely Vain and jealous person and
he's an egomaniac who can't stand even
an inkling of criticism but these
negative character traits were not his
biggest issue his biggest issue is that
Yoko saw humans as mere play things as
props for his grotesque art pieces he
saw himself as a superb and the chosen
being and he saw humans as inferior
lower life forms because of this he
never even considered the possibility
that a human child like muichiro would
be able to defeat him and take his life
that is why he underestimated muichiro
again and again that is why he walked
away when he had the chance to finish
him off and that is why he ultimately
lost and the fact that a guy with so
many character flaws was still chosen by
muzon to be his fifth strongest demon
Moon says a lot about moves on himself
muzon liked the fact that gyoko was so
desperate to please him that he took
sick pleasure in the act of muzon
touching him and that he considered
muzon to be an evolved Superior being
while humans were lower life forms muzon
liked these things because they are in
line with his own megalomaniacal view of
the world and muzan's own tendency to
look down upon and underestimate humans
would also cost him dearly in the end
but that is a story for another day if
you liked hearing about gyoko's life and
backstory don't ignore this video that
covers the backs story of every single
upper Moon Link in the description and
on screen if you enjoyed this video and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like right now and if you're one
of the over 50 of people who watch our
videos but still haven't taken the time
to subscribe yet do me a big favor and
subscribe right now and also hit that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications